I wonder all right folks this one is
just gonna be wearing nonsensical but
yeah I just wanted to do it I am going
to sort every incarnation of the doctor
from Doctor Who into a Hogwarts house
because when you've got your major
fandoms sometimes it's fun to just smash
them together and I guarantee I'm gonna
get some pushback and some argument on
some of these for a variety of reasons
but we're going all the way through from
the first doctor William partner
Hartnell all the way up through the
current doctor Jodie Whittaker and we
are gonna sort them into one of four
Hogwarts houses Hufflepuff Ravenclaw
Gryffindor and my own house
Slytherin let's start with the first
Doctor Who this was one of the easier
ones the first doctor is a ravenclaw now
something that is going to come up
repeatedly as I go through these is I do
have to take into account with some of
these doctors how they changed over the
course of their run some didn't change
much at all some did change notably and
so the question becomes is what we saw
towards the beginning is that truer to
the house they should be in or as what
we saw later toward us that they should
be in in the case of the first doctor
it's I'm gonna say that we got a sort of
based off how he started and he started
very ravenclaw very focused on the
science what he could learn and actually
going out of his way to ensure in that
they stay on the planet that they're on
just so he can study and learn more
about it that having the very second
story that I've been to the Daleks he
has a disregard for for other people's
concerns and he just he's focused on
getting his data now he softens and he
becomes
more empathetic as the time goes on but
that is a ravenclaw softening not you
know someone who was forcing themselves
into ravenclaw and showing their true
form he softened over time but still
very much a ravenclaw so becomes the
second doctor and I have a feeling most
people would put second doctor as a
Hufflepuff I'm gonna make an argument
that he's a Slytherin and here's why the
vast majority of his Hufflepuff
tendencies are an affectation and that's
not headcanon that's how the guy
operates the bumbling the oh ma Oh My
giddy aunt and all of that he does that
so that he is underestimated or
unnoticed or disregarded by the people
who he's trying to stop he doesn't want
them to take him seriously he wants them
to think that he is an idiot but he's
not you want proof of that look at his
first story look at power of the dots or
look at the animated recreation of
powering the Daleks
he is very calculating he's still a
little weird still a little quirky but
there's a lot of silence from him he's
watching he's observing he's figuring
out how to operate and he soon as time
goes on adopts this bungling lovable
persona but underneath it he's always
watching he's always observing he's
always calculating he's always figuring
out how to twist the situation to the
direction he wants it now does that mean
the Hufflepuff tendencies that he masked
behind the board just created out of
whole cloth and there's no basis behind
them no absolutely not
yeah I think he's you could make an
argument that he's a bit like Harry
Potter where Harry Potter when the point
I'm really showing minder stuff when the
sorting hat got put on him he could have
very easily been put into Slytherin but
he chose Gryffindor I think that if the
if the sort of head was put onto the
second doctor if he chose Hufflepuff it
would put him there but I think in his
heart of hearts he's really a Slytherin
least
that's my take on it so third doctor
third doctor ZZ third doctors are
Gryffindor all the way just you know
thunder in with a with sort of a taking
charge and prepared to throw down and
just being suave and in command and
always on top of things and being very
self-assured of himself he's very
Gryffindor top to bottom and it just
suits him and I mean Jon Pertwee's just
great for that because he exudes that
level of confidence that level of
self-assuredness and that is very
Gryffindor fourth doctor fourth doctor
was hard because the fourth doctor is
weird and I'm like I don't know what to
do with you and I could make an argument
for him in almost any house so
ultimately in deciding what to do with
the fourth doctor I looked at Harry
Potter and go is there any character
that's any kind of like equivalent to
him at all anything even close that I
can use as a guide yeah I would say that
he is weird and doesn't fit into many
places in very much the same way that
Luna Lovegood does is weird and doesn't
fit too many places and if Luna is gonna
be put in ravenclaw I'm gonna say that's
probably the best fit for for the Fourth
Doctor as well I'm like I said I'm not
super committed on this because I
couldn't make an argument for almost any
house for him I would like mice my
backup on this would be Hufflepuff but
I'm going ravenclaw with him but like
the weird quirky end of Ravenclaw the
Luna Lovegood end of Ravenclaw as
opposed to the first doctor you know
hard science end of it
all right fifth doctor he's a Slytherin
and again I feel like if you go
superficial you might think Hufflepuff
because especially to look at him like
really no he's a Slytherin this doctor
is possibly the most mercenary the most
pragmatically quickest to turn to true
violence because you might say the third
doctor because he had the Venusian
Aikido but that was generally non-fatal
that was to layout guards on there
Bax v doctor shot Omega v doctor
ground gold dust into the chest of a
Cyberman to suffocate it v dr. devised a
poison gas to kill the Silurians and the
sea Devils he is ruthless
he doesn't present himself that way he
presents himself very very calm very
collected very gentlemanly he's brutal
and in a way that to me just reads
Slytherin because when push comes to
shove if he feels he doesn't have the
luxury of the moral high ground he will
abandon it very quickly to take what
would to take the road that will just
get the job done and that is very
Slytherin Sixth Doctor this one this one
would be tricky if it wasn't for Big
Finish and that's kind of the case with
almost everything regarding the Sixth
Doctor Big Finish makes everything
easier um he's a Gryffindor and again a
lot of that much like the third doctor
just has to come with the level of
self-assuredness he has the the level of
confidence the level of bluster like
he's he's prepared to go into a
situation goes I'm sure everything's
gonna be fine and just strides on in
there he's not cautious he's not
calculated he's not even particularly
concerned or most of the time he's just
like it'll be fine cuz I'm me and that's
that's kind of a Gryffindor thing yeah
Seventh Doctor this was another easy one
Seventh Doctor is a Slytherin now unlike
say when we talked the first Doctor and
I went by how he initially appeared as
how it was gonna sort him and sort of
took his shift as a softening of him we
got the opposite going on with the
seventh The Seventh Doctor initially
presents himself very bumbling but by
the time we get to something like say
remembers the Daleks he has revealed
himself to be very calculating very
manipulative
very willing to set things up too that
will have very harsh outcomes he's
prepared to do those things that he's
willing to do those things and he will
execute those things and again it's the
pragmatism
it's the mercenary nature it is I am
going to use you because that is going
to get me the outcome I need I'm not
gonna try and negotiate with you I'm not
gonna try and talk you into something
I'm gonna get you to do what I what I
need you to do through whatever means I
am going to need to do it that's pretty
dang Slytherin 8th doctor we get a
Gryffindor again again it's it's the
it's the swagger it's the
self-assuredness it's that I got this
and everything will be fine
sort of thing that he's got going on and
it's interesting with the 8th doctor
because it's it's actually a little bit
toned down especially if you're gonna
compare to the 3rd or the 6th but it's
still there he still got that level of
swagger he still got that level of
self-assuredness and self confidence so
that brings us to the one that is the
biggest yes work for me because I know
the least about him that's the war
doctor and this one's really hard
because I haven't taken in any of the
extra material with the war doctor yet I
haven't listened to any of the war
doctor audios yet I really want to but
the box sets are expensive man I haven't
read any of the books etc so what I know
from him only comes from day the doctor
but I know that day the doctor is him
basically sick of what he's been doing
up to that point and I don't have what
he was doing after that point actually
in front of me as a template however
given what the 8th doctor was and sort
of accepting that what he was was not
going to work in the time war and then
he had to go at a very far end from what
he had been in that incarnation
instinctively I'm gonna say that
Slytherin because if you're gonna fight
a war a war that you need to
not just be on the right side of but win
you get a Slytherin you get somebody who
will do whatever it takes and whether or
not he actually did that again I don't
know I haven't I haven't listened to or
read enough of the material to know for
certain that certainly in neither the
doctor seemed to be the intent behind
him so like said that one's the most
blind guess I've got to lay out there
but we'll move on to the ninth doctor
and finally we got ourselves a
Hufflepuff it took a while and and like
I said I'm sure some will argue second
doctor was I'm still gonna I'm stand by
what I said but ninth doctor
yeah he's a Hufflepuff he's trying to be
harder than he is he's trying to put up
a front a bit but he is a wash in
empathy in needing to try and help in
whatever way he is able to needing the
connections again needing his
friendships and not in a camaraderie
sort of Gryffindor way he needs those
connections and the importance of those
in the prioritizing of those over that
like the decision he makes in the
parting of ways when said you know are
you coward or murderer he says coward
every time that's the Hufflepuff choice
and it's wonderful
so now 10th doctor 10th doctors a
Gryffindor again it's the cockiness is
the swagger and 10th doctor especially
until he got taken down a peg a few
times towards the tail end of his run uh
very self-assured of himself he was
always certain that he had the moral
high ground and the absolute moral
authority to do what he was gonna do he
considered himself to be the highest
authority he just knew and not like not
in the Slytherin I'm just better than
you way
although he dipped into that a tiny bit
towards the end of his run but in the
Gryffindor I have the superior position
I'm I'm defending the superior place I
have the superior moral values way
because slytherins can get senses of
superior because they just think they're
a little bit amélie better
Gryffindor's can get senses of
superiority because they think they're
always on the right side of whatever's
going on so it's a moral superiority as
opposed to a personal one and the Tenth
Doctor had that all over the place and
that brings us to the eleventh Doctor
another Hufflepuff I debated on him I
because I did find myself wondering if
like what the sack conductor is his
quirkiness is the bow tie and the the
sort of silliness and the jammie Dodgers
and the Fez are these affectations but
the thing is he doesn't really do those
in front of his enemies or the VIII was
trying to figure out he does those with
his friends the Fez is something he does
with the people who he loves that's just
who he is very much the eleventh Doctor
is what you see is what you get it's
just what you get is kind of weird but
he's very he's very much a focus on his
relationships and his connections and he
knows that those are important now he's
got his dark moments and he certainly
tries to go solo for a little bit and
gets wrote back in by the whole
impossible girl thing and his approach
to that he's trying to be a bit more
ravenclaw he's trying to just have it be
about the mystery but he gets invested
in the person because the ulema doctors
a people person the eleventh Doctor is a
Hufflepuff as for the twelfth doctor
twelfth doctor you've got yourself a
ravenclaw and much like the first doctor
he is a ravenclaw who softens over time
because starting out like he knows what
he's here to do he knows you know what
information he needs to get how to
figure it out
he gets very focused on mysteries and
solving stuff I mean that's the entire
premise of listen he softens over time
he comes to better appreciate his
relationships to the point that he is
prepared to wreck everything in hellbent
but well we won't go down that path so
he gets very invested in his
relationships as time goes on but I
still say Ravenclaw's the better fit
even though that by the end his his big
claim is you know just its kind and that
that is his goal and I do believe he's
softened to that point but even
underneath that there's still that core
of him wanting to just get the
information and figure out what is going
on that's part of why he keeps missing
yes it's his friend yes there's somebody
but there's also like well we have to
try this if we don't run this experiment
we'll never know and he you know he
cannot stop himself from just poking at
it and seeing what the reaction is and
that's pretty dang ravenclaw that brings
us to the 13th doctor and she's a hovel
she is adorably Hufflepuff just she's
just she's just thrilled to be with her
friends and to be traveling and to see
what there is to see when push comes to
shove she'll make her stands she will
stand she will stand her ground and
she'll know what she's fighting for and
fight if she needs to but that's not why
she's here she's here to have fun see
new things and be with her friends she's
a huh flat heart she can tap another
stuff when she needs to as most of the
doctors do but that's where her heart is
we've got a Hufflepuff doctor right now
and it's interesting to me that at least
to my way of thinking we didn't start
getting huh folders until the modern era
mm so that gives us three Ravenclaw's
three Hubble puffs four Gryffindor's
four slytherins that's how I
sorted the doctors I suspect people are
gonna disagree with me
how would you sort the doctors into the
various houses of Hogwarts whatever your
sorting hat says drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it
if you wish to support me there's also
my patreon down there plus a link to my
paypal if you want to help in one-time
sort of capacity
it helps me cover my bills there's also
the like button it's a big help go ahead
and hit that subscribe if you haven't
Pat and spread this around it's fun
right show it to people there's other
links tons of stuff you also don't have
to do it I'd appreciate it but I'm the
end of the day you're the council not
just running these very ridiculous
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]